this monday i love your sign by the way
and your glasses thank you so much
this monday is so exciting because it's
world teacher's day
and if there was ever a year that we all
understand what teachers go through
we always have had respect for teachers
but never in our wildest dreams did we
think we'd be playing
teacher as well as parent and provider
and friend
and trying to be everything for our kids
and
i don't know about you guys but my kid
doesn't see me as her teacher
no she doesn't neither of them do olive
nor frankie
and it was so weird to try and play all
of these
parts you know but when we weren't like
like with each other which was basically
what home school
felt like and we'd be in the zone and
talking about venus
or making a clock and discussing time it
was like the fantasy i always had when i
thought of being a parent
and doing like homework with my kids it
would settle in and it was the most
amazing moment ever
and then it would go back to here
how is homeschooling going for you
meredith
hi oh my gosh um this is lucas
hi lucas you just started middle school
oh my gosh how's it going it's going
really well
he he's loving it he just started uh
playing the saxophone
yeah lucas how are you liking homeschool
what's the vibe
are you in are you out i'm in it's not
well gosh i have two girls i would love
you to talk to
olive and frankie and you can share that
spirit with them because
i think that if anything you guys are
doing better than adults with all of
this
so thank you meredith and lucas
i really really appreciate bonding with
you over this
and your tone of positivity and can do
is awesome
[Music]